i'll give an introduction then we can
get started
okay it's a good place to start is the
guide page pdemodels.nb
okay and because it's easy to click from
there
join the source live stream
we are talking about
physicalizing our
pde system in a sense
i mean so assuming i want the diffusion
equation for example
right how do i get that
well if you if it's if it's non-physics
you can go down
to use it just a generic model to get a
diffusion equation
what's the what what what what what is
it it says generic down there no no i
understand what's what's the guide page
called
um do i have this or does it just get
updated today
no it's been there forever
from the source there it is
okay
hmm
where's generics here i mean so so
hmm
i mean i'm not hugely enthusiastic about
you know the immediate physicalization
of these things i mean some of them like
diffusive diffusion term convection term
that makes sense to me
uh okay do we have units in all these
things
like when we're doing heat transfer do
we have units though
all right well where do i start where
should i start should i start with the
diffusion equation
i think you should start with the things
that that you know
acoustic heat transfer mass transport
let's start with the differential model
and then go from there yeah
so so the first argument is the
variables is that correct
yes i mean
okay variables parameters okay okay but
it's a generalized notion of variables
you know it's dependent and independent
i understand that
that list so how do i know what
variables
are i have to specify for this model
how do i know what variables i have to
specify for this so it's always the same
it's always the dependent variable then
you have either a time dependent or
a non-time dependent version and then
the independent variables
as a list as a list how so there's
so there's an assumption that there's a
single independent variable is that
correct
in this form yes there's other forms
where you have a list of dependent
variables
so what about the wave equation for
example that's a single
single single equation so it's just any
dependent variable you as you like to
name it
no but i understand that the wave
equation has time and it has space
which one is the dependent variable
which one is an independent variable
so the dependent variable is the
variable i mean
i mean t and x are both independent
variables
okay so here they're both independent
variables or not yes
so why are they listed i don't
understand why is the x in braces
so you might have a two-dimensional
acoustic i'm not well aware of that but
i don't think that's an expect
good enough well stephen i think that
the thing is we distinguish we're
streaming between
time and spatial variables in our pde
solutions so if you look at that
frequency domain acoustic model
that's a purely spatial model but it's
using this frequency domain
modeling system so so let's let's be
clear what our meta model of physics is
here
okay is it the case that you are
assuming
time is a single variable and then you
have
some number of dimensions of space is
that correct
so so or in this case it could be
frequency equivalently to time
okay it could be wave number presumably
equivalently to space
too or not not not in
acoustics but maybe they could be but
that
that we haven't seen that convention
used
um
where's laplace's equation
is there a laplace equation here where
is laplace's equation
it's it's not equation
so i mean it
we we can so la plus we need those
we need those that we need laplace
helmholtz wave equation
we need the obvious named equations
classical pdes you mean
yeah we need them we need them before we
announce something with acoustics we
need the freaking laplace equation
the diffusion term is a generalization
of the level i'm well aware
i don't care just like a polygon is a
generalization of a triangle but we
can't
you know there are many more people who
understand triangles and understand
you know seventeen-sided polygons mm-hmm
equation is a well-known pde understood
by many people
who do not go in for you know yes the
laplace equation is a diffusion term
equal to zero right
uh it's really important that we do this
and not
okay so the the pdes that have classic
names
need to have functions here so are there
any in addition to diffusion helmholtz
wave equation
i mean clearly there are nonlinear ones
like sign gordon and all these kinds of
things
um but uh i think those are probably not
what we can deal with because we're
dealing here
with am i correct we're basically
dealing with linear pdes
is that true no that's not true we can
do non-linear pdes but the model form of
the equation is given
and that's what says the model partial
differential equation has the following
form that's the form we constructed
where's fluid mechanics we haven't
there are lots of domains we haven't
covered fluid dynamics is one okay
okay so the euler equations for example
we don't have
we don't have those no
could we have those i mean are they are
they the same with the finite element
method
okay
okay but we sure can have a laplace and
helmholtz and then yes
which are like they should be the
beginning of this before we get to any
of these other things
at the top yeah i mean i guess at
terminology questions do we want to
so so most of these models and terms
are set up as things which we build up
equations with so we want something
that's just called laplace equation and
just
the laplace equation that's what i would
think fine
i mean the way that we do boundary
conditions
with finite elements you can't do that
um okay i need to understand that i
don't understand that yet so let's loop
back to that when i've understood that
from this other stuff
okay yeah okay
so
okay there are no parameters here even
though
it's meaningless to have unit
coefficients
in this acoustic equation is it not
there lots of parameters
no no i understand but here with the
default with no parameters
there are no that what we if i were
doing this i
it's a pity we can't do this with a um
let's do it with a heat transfer model
because i i'm a little bit more familiar
with what that should be
oh boy
i really don't think it's a good idea to
use capital letter variable names here
i don't know what the right thing to do
is but i don't think that's it
use theta for temperature it's another
pretty common thing to use does that
make sense
yep
okay i don't understand this i don't
understand what this is
this isn't a model this is a left-hand
side of an equation presumably
in what sense is that a model
do you understand what i'm asking what
is this thing
this is the thing which is going to be
set equal to zero correct
actually that doesn't seem right that's
just a
the the well go ahead
what is this thing that you call a model
do you understand my question yeah i
mean are you asking me so yes i'm asking
you
i mean i'm asking somebody here i don't
know who is responsible for this
but whoever's responsible for this i'm
asking you
okay so the idea behind this modeling
language is that we
provide um building blocks of
um of model company i understand but
what is that
object that object returns a part of the
equation that can be
that's not called a heat transfer model
what is the definition of this
object in other words if you were
documenting that object
there that is not defining a model it's
it's sort of an
operator okay then that's what we should
call it it's not aiming
go back up in the notes
okay stop
there it is okay that's what it is in
its full generality
but a model would be equal to zero
is this thing equal to zero
i mean it will only become a full model
if you actually specify the boundary
conditions to um
okay then that isn't a model then what
this is is i don't know what the right
term for it is but it doesn't model
well but stephen the thing is that that
that thing without the boundary
conditions
is is equal to zero
i don't care i'm just saying you
shouldn't call it a model
it's not a model i mean it
i mean they're sure we can change it to
some other name yeah that's what i'm
talking about that's what these reviews
are about it's trying to figure out how
to make it so people can actually
understand what we have
and so we actually have the elementary
stuff as well as the super advanced
stuff
now let's look at the actual form you've
got here
this thing here oh boy it's an inactive
div
wow that's exotic and what's this weird
thing here
what's that so that's the
the i mean the coefficient it's minus
one is the default
value what is it in levels of braces
because it's dot multiplied with the
gradient with an
active gradient in general stephen the
diffusion coefficient is a matrix
so in one one independent variable yes
it is in one dimension where it's the
diffusion coefficient of the diffusion
constant of one
somehow that's the default in this model
that the diffusion constant is one with
no units is that correct
yes
and that div
is specifying its variable there which
is okay
and and actually i mean that's a
gradient
right oh yeah it says that's an active
gradient
and that's an ordinary dot there yes
okay so
okay so where do i start seeing this
thing be solved
um in the scope section presumably
you'll find examples some
but i mean obviously you should show the
thing getting solved in the basic
oh my gosh
okay
so all right so this is the beginning of
the boundary condition specification
is that right
um i don't see where you this this here
here here
here yes that's the boundary condition
right yes correct
okay so how about explaining okay so
what's the general form of boundary
conditions
so um the general form is that you first
have
um the location where the boundary
condition is then the vars and
parameters as specified for the
differential equation operator model
however you want to call it
and then a specialization of what this
specific boundary condition is supposed
to do
what do you mean by do i mean if you
want uh
boundary condition you need to tell the
boundary condition what value it should
have at that specific location
how does it know its surface temperature
what what is the what is
what other things could i specify other
than surface temperature there for the
heat temperature condition you couldn't
specify anything else but there's other
boundary conditions that have other
um so mathematically what we're
specifying i mean
you know it's dirichlet conditions it's
annoying conditions things like that
everything that that ends in condition
will result in a dirichlet condition
and everything that was that's called
something value will result in annoyment
value
and the key functionality that we're
providing is the knowledge of how to set
these dirichlet neumann values up
because they're really complicated to
set up
and this is the simplification or is an
interface
to generate directly conditions and
neumann values that um
that okay so so let me ask a couple of
questions here so at the mathematical
level before we get
to the physical modeling right
um what is the layer
i mean what we have right now is a bunch
of
ways to specify boundary conditions
um which i have only ever copied
examples with them in
but what is the you know we got a level
which is the pure mathematical level
then we're going to this level which is
some kind of physics level
right that's correct what is the
intermediate level or is that does there
not need to be one for some reason
for me that doesn't it's not obvious so
what would be
how would you write this out as if i if
i would just evaluate that
you'd get you'd get directly conditions
okay hold on let me just do it
let me just go ahead and
maybe do this in another notebook so i
don't mess this up
[Music]
oh that didn't work oh because you need
to copy the rest of it as well
no no no no i'm just gonna do it here
what what's going on here there's a typo
oh okay
so that's what this actually is and by
the way it might be useful to show that
in the documentation
okay
i've typically done that on the
reference pages for the conditions and
values
but i can do it here no i'm not sure
okay all right so let me understand this
so this is the other way around this
says
what the constraint is
and then where that constraint occurs is
that correct that's correct okay
so for some reason this has switched it
around yes we've switched it around
because
when i look at the pde model and i see
the equation and i see the boundary
conditions the first thing i need to
know is
what type of boundary condition is and
then that's what's in the name
and then where it's applied the
specifics of the exact value are not
that important right away
but this is optimized for readability
well
so what would parameters be so
parameters
i'm the parameters used by this no i see
that i see that that's the parameters
that go into the equations
um and which ultimately would be would
potentially be
part of those boundary conditions
correct okay but so anyway so
the basic scheme which i'm not totally
sold in terms of argument order and so
on
but the basic scheme is that
whatever this original thing you're
currently calling a model which should
be called something different
um is that
has the parameters there
this this is vars that first argument
here is that correct
yes okay and the second argument is the
parameters
that's correct
okay so
okay so let's see how we solve this
so if we if i take
boy so this could have units the 343
could have units correct
this 343 sound speed could be meters per
second right
you could put units in there right i'll
check that
well you have to you must know because
it's got to have a whole bunch of code
to deal with units
then it doesn't well it needs it okay
okay because what people are going to do
is they're going to say sound speed goes
to
and let's say going to say control
equals speed of sound
right mass density control equals you
know density of
aluminum you know alloy such and such
right
so that absolutely has to work and that
means you've got to be able to untangle
in the pre-processing for the pdes
you've got to be able to untangle the
units
and re-insert them at the end right and
i don't know exactly how but
is rob here can you comment on the
infrastructure for that well i think res
reasserting in the end is going to be
is going to be going to figure out how
to do it because
we'll know because i mean what we're
doing is we're setting up
we're setting up models or equations or
whatever we want to call them
that set up an equation that you then
and you solve it's not
i don't have a function which is called
solve acoustic equation
i understand so you solve the equation
and what the equation has units in it
and the result should be an
interpolating function either with units
or some kind of
thing where the units are wrapped around
it yeah but that's a okay
so stephen that's a that's a whole
nother i mean that's a huge try and get
units
injected in any solved generally okay
but then i'm afraid this isn't going to
work i mean because people are going to
give this with units so you've got to
figure out what are you going to do with
that
you're going to reduce it to base si
units or what are you going to do
yeah i think we would reduce the base si
units
okay and then you give a result
and then how do people interpret that
result
okay you gotta you gotta come up with a
solution to this okay
and and i suspect the correct solution
is
i mean i think you should examine what
is involved in getting
a you know units will float through and
desolve
right they can be stripped at the
beginning the solution is made
they can be inserted at the end yes
that's that's that's a significant
project to make that well i i understand
so to figure out what to do
i mean okay so i mean
having this you know documenting this as
an
oh it'll lose the units is a pretty
unfortunate thing to do
but you know maybe if it's experimental
enough i suppose we can do that
am i making sense i i i see what you're
saying stephen and i
and i i think it's correct we should
think about this
um i do want however to point out that
um
in my opinion the the value of these
functionality
is actually in the providing of the pde
term operator model whatever you want to
call it because those
are not easy to set up and i completely
agree and i've been pushing for this for
15 years or something
for us to have this so the thing i think
we should do first is laplace equation
before we do all these fancy equations
but anyway that that's you'll do that
so i now also i also agree with that we
can add them and i will add them
one thing to keep in mind though is that
um
we need to have a certain level of
complexity
in these things that we model from the
physics point of view to be able to say
that the approach that
the framework we put into place works
generally oh i agree
i agree but i i just said just don't
make the mistake of forgetting the basic
things i'll do that i'll add them okay
okay fine but but but so for those
things
see the problem is as soon as you call
something sound speed
you're setting up something that needs
units okay
that's the problem so you know if this
was called
if it was just parameter x
you know i'm not saying it should be one
wouldn't expect you to have units for
the laplace equation for the helmholtz
equation i don't expect units
but i do expect units by the time i'm
filling in something called sound speed
if you look at the notes it is
documented the units there
if you scroll up in the notes okay okay
well fine but but so
i have another question the physical
quantities framework
how does that relate i mean presumably
you can give entities instead of the
the string sound speed here is that
correct no
well you need to figure that out right
you do you know about the physical
quantities framework
yes but the the problem with that is
that it's somewhat limited if you want
to have
material parameter of something very
specific most of the time i just don't
find what i need
okay well then make sure it gets put in
there because it should be in there
okay i'll i'll be right back so i mean
that's i mean that's what physical
quantities are about and
the whole point is we can analyze you
know our dimensional analysis system and
so on work with those physical
quantities
am i making sense yeah so
you know that's and for example you
should be able to use that
to you know de-dimensionalize
things if necessary but the point is
that that has to okay so
and the and the canonical names you're
using here have to agree with the ones
for physical quantities right
they do they do that to the best of my
knowledge they do okay
okay so then you should support either i
mean in the canonical form here i think
should be an entity there
but you can for convenience you can let
people enter them as strings
does that make sense yep okay
so if you scroll up stephen
so just the documentation of the
parameters there there should be a table
at the end for everything
there it is okay all right well
that's not going to always work i mean
i'm sorry people are going to give
temperatures in fahrenheit and they're
going to do all of fahrenheit
differences and so on
all kinds of funky things right
and i don't really understand that was a
really bad example
that's one thing we can't do the
temperature we can't do
temperature differences why not
that's one of the failings of our unit
system
no no we can do temperature differences
we can we can we go i mean
what's tricky is yeah anyway we can do
temperature differences
um okay what happens if i
want gravitational waves and i want a
quadrupole source
then you'll have to model it with
several dipole sources
okay so you we have monopoly and dipole
sources
i can see that yeah and then if you want
more
higher order source um sources you'll
have to model them yourself
that's the limitation of the model
that's fine
um
okay let's see here so
what should i okay so what what is
something like this
how is that used
it should say there in the very
beginning typically used for
i don't think that font is right but
that's a very minor thing
okay represents time frequency domain
absorbing boundary condition
absorbing bound acoustic absorbing value
so since we can't have infinite domains
in finite elements or how do people
simulate it
well they simulate a finite domain and
they have an
absorbing boundary value
so that's what it the text says to you
know
but so this object
is going to be something this is
a neumann value
which so in other words what you're
saying is in the pde
this is like there could be a piece in
the pde that says you know why prime of
blah blah blah equals blah blah blah
comma neumann value whatever is that
right is that how we set it up
yes i think that's correct and if you if
you scroll up to the top
there is an example of how it's used so
it says
right at the top first so there
there it says acoustic model equal equal
absorbing
about acoustic absorbing value so the
acoustic model
operator whatever gives the part of the
equation
while the value or the condition gives
the boundary conditions
i don't understand that i mean normally
aren't the boundary conditions separate
you know you have in the bulk yes you
know whatever
that's you know but the reason but we
cannot really do that and the reason
why because the neumann value um
does not necessarily depend on the
dependent variable and if it's floating
around
in the list of equations and boundary
conditions we cannot associate the
neumann value to the
part of the pde you have to think about
coupled pdes for example
then it's not clear which dependent
variable a specific norman value belongs
to that's why it's part of the equation
so that we can associate a specific
neumann value to a specific part of the
equation okay but in the way that we've
set it up
okay we have the idea here this says
a dirichlet condition which says this
dependent variable at this position
i mean why okay the question
normally
they depend on the weak that they come
from the weak form of the equation
that's actually used to solve so they
depend
explicitly on the actual equation
that's being used not so it's not just
an extra term you add
you put it in my naive understanding of
this they they have a derivative piece
right there
they depend on on things like fluxes and
so on right correct
yes it's it's actually an integral
condition basically well is it a flux
condition is that what it really is
what is it yes go ahead
it's a flux condition so it's basically
everything that's
behind the divergence so you have it
inactive diff and then there comes a
whole slew of stuff and all that stuff
relates to the neumann value
and that that blah blah blah
dot gradient stuff that is a flux
and okay so in other words when you've
got a div here
the grad inside here is yes and that's
the thing yes you want to set equal to
zero
yes and that that's done in a weak sense
that's what's rob what rob is referring
to what do you mean by that
so like an integral equation so if you
look at theory
um sorry neumann value page reference
page it's actually explained there
what did i do wrong here probably
another end to end
a spell checking should deal with that
somebody should refine that
can we can we get that um
okay
so um
it's in the details section well i'm
trying to understand this
equals equals neumann value and then
there's i see there's a dirichlet
condition
which is over here and then there's a
neumann value
right and because the directly condition
always
has a reference to the dependent
variable we know where it belongs
but the neumann value is just one there
so if you have u and v
as dependent variables in the system of
equations you don't know where to put
that neumann value
and it actually makes sense to to make
this noise
part of the equation yeah this makes
because it's in the integrals are
related
i remember when we designed this yes
this was a painful design process yeah
this pain that we thought about a long
time
i think it's pretty good actually this
is correct yeah
um so in a sense this is a
generalization
okay okay okay fine i get it
all right it's a little bit of a weird
name there
we we stuck with trying to make the
names
um consistent so that if you look at the
name and it says something value you
already know
this is part of the big problem that i
have with this is
you know there's basic mechanics we
don't even have
you know basic ode mechanics
we have not physicalized things to talk
about basic ode mechanics
right except in the framework except
in our i mean like you know lagrange's
equations are good
god knows what else right basic monitor
well i understand but we don't have
we don't have that wrapping
here right now maybe that's because
i mean you know one thing to say is
there are a lot more odes that make
sense to solve than pdes that one can
reasonably solve
i mean that's one argument for that that
is
that but i mean one would expect given
that one has
so okay argue through this okay
i mean we've got is that a correct
reason why we're doing
this way because there are only like
five pdes that one can solve type thing
no i mean so explain
so no i think the big things and oliver
can
complement the big strength of the
framework that we have
for for pde modeling and so on is that
it allows you to mix different kinds of
physics
i understand that this is not my
question my question is if you're
looking at the system from the outside
right i would say okay show me a
harmonic oscillator
oh we don't have those we have uh
complicated acoustic absorb
absorption models but we don't have a
harmonic oscillator
how come
i see what you're saying so we haven't
built a modeling
layer i mean to be honest i think that
but that's a lot easier most people can
write down a harmonic oscillator whereas
they get
the other thing is that when you model
those things of some complexity you
abandon equations
or you have something where as a modeler
you don't actually explicitly use
equations
that's what system modeler bond graphs
and all of these tools do
they get you a level above equations and
equations is sure
it's like the machine language you
eventually compile it to equations
i understand but my question is
for you know for purposes of explaining
what's going on
and for purposes of having i mean i
don't understand why we don't have
harmonic oscillator
i mean by the time we have an acoustic
model we should have a harmonic
oscillator
right because the harmonic oscillator
also has certain parameters
you know it has a natural frequency it
has a damping et cetera et cetera et
cetera which we can understand yeah but
but
the problem with this that same same
damn problem with the named equations
they don't compose you can't they're not
the building block they're sort of a
final piece
you know they might have parameters so
there's like some flexibility but
they don't compose there's no compass
ability
that's what what happened with the ode
modeling frameworks
they built something that has
composability that's what all the
you know that's what bond graphs do
that's what system modeler modelica does
that's what they all do there's sort of
composability you can actually build
something
how is this composable
it's composable in a much narrower sense
in the sense that you you you get a
a a a core model and you get a bunch of
boundary conditions
then you do you add the main domain
domain you can mix the domains
they happily mix so you can have
multiple physics so for example if
i have an acoustic model and i also have
a diffusion equation running
um a better example might be you want to
to model uh fluid dynamics and heat
transfer
so yeah we don't have fluid dynamics yet
no no but it's coming
even if we don't have the model right
now the first thing is we can add that
and the second thing is you could still
write them all there and
use these operators or these terms or
whatever
to to complement them i see
and so your point is that the harmonic
oscillator kernel
is kind of trivial but these are not
trivial
yes yes yeah but
it's the same for the same for the
engineering the ode style modeling
you know but i think that there's
there's as much composability if we had
a harmonic oscillator
but the minute you make it then equation
you can i like
to understand so it shouldn't okay so
that's your argument for why these are
terms
not equations which i'm beginning to buy
right that's why you don't want to give
the thing as boom an equation
but there is still still a harmonic
oscillator kernel
you know sure that isn't
um and you might want to model an array
of harmonic oscillators
i mean you right which is fine but you
could do if you had them as terms rather
than equations correct
exactly right so so that is an argument
for having laplace operator
you know wave equation operator
rather than wave equation i agree with
that yeah
absolutely okay so now my next question
would be
in what sense could this be thought of
as an acoustic
model operator of some kind so you can
directly feed this to
i mean the for example the the frequency
version you can directly feed this to nd
so
to end the eigen system and compute
eigen values and eigen frequencies no no
i understand that but but
this thing is what it is
is it's a term and an equation
yep right what term is it really
what is the physics of what this term is
it's the term of the full dimensional
object that you want to model the
boundary conditions are there
okay but what is it physically i mean
like in the case of
well i'm trying to get a it's not a very
good argument because
because yes i mean like if if you ask
for a plus equation you know
del squared you know for electrostatics
for example
del squared phi is just
you know i don't know what you call that
it's what do you call that i mean del
squared is the
is the operator what's that you might
call the plus the posse in turn i mean
so the the thing i agree with you
the naming is is difficult in that sense
because we've we've used the dependent
variable
in the equation the operator would be a
function basically
i agree i agree which is not what we
want although there are
plenty of people who will talk about
using the heat operator or the heat
kernel
to mean the kernel right and that might
be useful in its own right
just like we have laplacian we could as
well have heat kernel
so i'm saying so you can say laplacian
of f
we could also say heat kernel of f
does that make some sense i'm trying to
think
um i mean it'll have parameters yes it
must have
because otherwise it's it's uh yeah
i think you're going to have a bunch of
placeholders for all the dependents
yeah i i don't know whether that makes
sense but i think in the case of the
heat tunnel it probably does make sense
and people use that terminology
just like they lose laplacian i mean you
could say why do we have a laplacian
why not make it from you know div grad
type thing
sure so this is this is going a bit in a
different direction this is
basic physics operators basically
i mean the the thing i'm concerned with
more is
is about engineering applications so
it's it's like it's tangential but
slightly different
yeah but i understand but but so okay so
might be a different
different or an additional project to do
something like that
yeah but we we are going to need that
because people i mean given the
framework you've made
the heat kernel and solving i mean you
know
okay let's come back to this
okay so
this thing you call acoustic model
it's a something term i don't know what
term it is
but it's a something term it's not a
model
right
um
what is the name of the equation that
we're dealing with here
so for the time dependent part it's a
wave equation and for the frequency
domain it's a
helmholtz equation both generalized
okay and and
are all applications of this referred to
as acoustics
i mean you know one talks about acoustic
modes in
who knows what i mean you know in
cosmology or
you know things like this they're still
called acoustics so maybe it's always
used but is there
i mean in um my question is is the term
acoustic which is a very
application specific term is that the
correct term for this
i mean maybe cosmology so i don't know
well we need we need to know the other
applications of this and whether it's
always called acoustic
i mean because the sound would be
another another
no term no acoustic is better than sound
acoustic is more general than sound
acoustic suggests pressure acoustics
maybe
what's that pressure acoustics
i don't think that helps what is
acoustics when it isn't
associated with pressure well i mean
that's making it more specific i don't
think that's right i think that the
the um okay in any case
it's acoustic sound hard value
wow these are really specific
okay so these are these are are terms
used
um in i know i know
i know that i know that yeah i mean i'm
specific but they're very hard to figure
out right but you see the problem is
okay look this is where we get into
trouble we are building
a you know a peninsula a tendril a
tentacle here
and the problem is unless we have the
main body of the animal
people won't even find the tentacle i
mean
so for my in my opinion the main body of
the animal
is fluid mechanics and structural
mechanics and those those two are
definitely myth
missing so and well but but it's more
than that it's it's
doing dealing with people yeah wait but
but this this
this is not maybe for other areas but
for engineering
we definitely need structural mechanics
and fluid dynamics
and not not harmonic oscillators and
things like that i mean i know but
for most of our users okay it's
wonderful to be able to build this
tentacle
we don't have good marketing into this
vertical basically
and that's the problem we can't really
you know yes we can do all this stuff
but it's not clear anybody's even gonna
notice
i mean this is a requested feature from
customers this modeling language for
i understand i understand i understand
wouldn't they why wouldn't they not
because i think that we need to make
sure that we have the the trunk of the
tree as well as its branches here
and that involves having you know things
like
laplace equations and so on things that
that's not helping that that's not
helping i'm not convinced even
now that's that's just not in that
market no but
heat transfer mass transport those are
big acoustics is probably a little
smaller
yes we started with two structural
mechanics fluid dynamics
super big those are very big he
transformed mass transport
we can have we'll need a separate
conversation about this
let's let's focus on this design
okay so first thing is
okay so
i don't know acoustic equation term
acoustic
that's a lot of type what could we
what could we just call it acoustic
model term
yeah we might be able to i feel
weird
or acoustic term perhaps i don't know
whether that even makes any sense what
would it do for the other cases
this term is not a heat transfer term
see what is it that what do you what is
the thing that's equal to zero
in these pdes what is the name for that
in my opinion it's always the model
everything is put on the left-hand side
in that
in that yeah but that's a that's a very
engineering thinking and it's not going
to work
i am an engineer right so
so the
um
does heat transfer term make any sense
or does that confuse things i mean if we
if we use the term
term here diffusion well you're using
diffusion term
term in my opinion a term is a single
a single object that you add with
plus or something some other method yes
but that's what you're doing for some of
these these things
you're adding it with multiple terms so
it's i mean it's diff
grad and uh you have conducted
the whole point is you can perfectly
well have something here
if you want coupled heat transfer you
would have
a sum of multiple ones of these terms
right
equal to they have one heat transfer
model with multiple variables you still
use only the heat transfer
model term whatever you what about the
right hand side the right hand side has
to have a boundary condition
equal to a number of zeros then whatever
or boundary
conditions right yeah okay and and that
actually makes sense for the mass
transport model because you want to
have mass transport for multiple species
and it actually works
so you can open multiple species in one
mass transport model
okay the term model isn't going to work
we've used it for other things it's not
going to work so
we need to figure out i mean and i don't
particularly like term either but what
is it
what is the left-hand side it's not a
model
a model is a more general thing it's the
whole ball of wax
yeah what is this
what is just that left-hand side what is
that called do we have you know
um
what is the right name for that
um i wonder if somebody on our live
stream has a suggestion here
uh heat transfer
components was one thing here yeah
what is it what what at a physical level
what is the thing
heat transfer balance or something what
is the
it's something like it's the thing but
not everything consider
is is balance but heat
again let's take electrostatics from
another point of view it's everything
except the zero on the right hand side
well is it always zero on the right hand
side well boundary conditions
that's the point it's boundary
conditions so but what is the thing
like like so it's supposed to be right
it applies to the dependent variable
i know that but but look just like you
have a bunch of things that you consider
to be fluxes
right that flow through the boundary so
it's almost
always zero right except at the boundary
yes so is that always true
is that always the case yeah i mean
because the right hand side is also
moved to the left-hand side basically
see so for the helmholtz equation of
something you move it to the left-hand
side yes yes you can always move to the
left-hand side and everything is in that
left-hand side part
okay so it's the finger other than the
boundary
it's always balanced to zero except that
the boundary
where you yes which sort of interfaces
with the environment
so it's like the bulk it's the value of
um
okay look it needs a name i don't know
what the right name is but i think
that's the right i mean
so so essentially what we're doing is
the left hand side of the equation is in
the bulk
and the right hand side is the boundary
body boundary
body bulk see unfortunately in some
cases it's more like welcoming some
it might be free space i mean it might
be that the the
the interior ah interior
but that's not necessarily correct
either because the boundary conditions
could be
wherever right that's true but it's you
know
interior exterior is not totally
terrible but but let's take a look at
what the structure of these things is
supposed to be
so you're saying that
but by the way i mean i assume that we
can do once
once you've specified the equations we
can do kind of industrial scale
um yes and we've versioned a whole
yes and we've written a whole set of
monographs about just that
wonderful yes
really a large scale and from
papers and stuff like oh this this is
another question for you stephen
so i have people that have used ndsolv
and pdes and stuff to
write papers and whatnot how can i make
those
notebooks and stuff like that available
easily available from within our
documentation
i'll have it in the notebook archive and
link to it i would think
no well i mean no no no no i think in
the 21st century we should we should
have something like an
automatic installer or something like
that not not not
linking so could we have for example a
guide page
advertising that saying this is a
repository of
externally contributed pde models or
something like that
um here's how you install it one line
well i think that's what our
repositories do
that's what we should do there if are
you saying that wait a minute
are you saying that people have created
things which are
specialized you know for for solving the
heat transfer in a starfish or something
is that the type of thing you're talking
about
no so so there's several people have
have used this to make their own models
or
application examples they've written
papers about and some of them have
contributed this to
our repository or one of the
repositories on github so for example
somebody did um a bell accused so they
analyzed the harmonics of a battery the
bottom line is they have made a model
that is based on
our building blocks but is a more
sophisticated model is that the idea
that it's not based on these building
blocks they're not but
i understand i understand that but it
could be based on these buildings yes
conceptually it's based on these
building blocks yes
correct okay so that's exactly what our
repositories are for and that's the
right way to handle this
for example look at the neural net
repository right it is exactly the same
kind of thing it is specific
you know if you look at the neural net
repository and by the way i'm going to
have to go in a few minutes here
um the if you look at the neural net
repository
sure here i mean let's just look at one
i mean this is
a particular right so this is
a particular model that uses our
building blocks here
right but this is a particular model as
a particular how do you install that
how do you get that you just say like
this you go
watch watch it's beautiful
okay this is because because we have the
wrong version but i mean
but it just works okay right but we
don't have like a pde model
kind of container so i think so i'm
saying we have to create something like
that okay
yep yep right there and then then that
this is the right way to do it
so then the documentation is on the web
and there is no documentation in product
for this nope
absolutely not stephen come on there
will not be and there will not be
because
we're moving all of our documentation to
the web
i mean it would be nice if if people
could just look at it in the
way they're accustomed to that's what
they will be able to do that's what our
repositories do we have a whole
framework for this that's how
it works beautifully nobody has a
problem with it
and there's there's the result okay so
that's what we would do here
right the this is literally a request i
have never heard
is a locally cached version of the
repositories
i mean it also happens to be crazy
because the repositories are huge
um i mean we have a good framework for
this and that's what you should use
i mean you know the neural net
repository the function repository
and by the way you can put some
preliminary things and users can put
things in the function repository
right this is the right way to do it and
okay so i mean we're gonna have to wrap
this meeting but
so we're gonna have to continue right
stephen yes we will have to continue
this is a good introduction
and it's very impressive what you guys
have done i'm i'm just
getting used to the fact that i know i
know it it's
it's it's a good process
right but i'm going to insist that you
have the more elementary things here i
don't want the same mistake that we made
with you know
regions and no triangles type thing we
had lots of triangles
by the way now we do now we have no no
no we really did from the get-go
from rejects we had lots of triangles i
understand you had lots of triangles but
you didn't have a way to specify them
no we did you insisted on these high
school triangles
okay so i'm insisting on college and we
built high school triangles
right college physics operators which is
fine
um yes so
it's fine i like the repository
different
but it's asking for wiki notebooks it's
very different because the repository
has all of the plumbing to just be able
to use the thing directly in the session
and it gets cached once it's i mean for
things that are big
this this network is now cached on this
machine
um bob on our live stream is saying flux
operator i guess in reference to what
the name of the thing
that is the the left-hand side but i
don't think that's quite right
is it there's more than the flux is just
one part of it
that you can specify stuff outside of
the flux yes so yeah it's more than flux
um what is it
gosh that that's crazy that there's no
the best of my knowledge there is no
name for that
well so we ought to make one up um yeah
i'm sure
that people can understand i mean it's
you know it's something like
acoustic interior yeah i mean
the the thing what we're doing is we're
relating the interior the full
the full dimensional model to the
boundary and that's
yeah right bulk to boundary basically
yes acoustic bulk
term oh well
sounds a bit bulky doesn't it
you don't like it i mean that but what
is the
again i'm going back to acoustic term
yeah i don't think probably i actually
don't think term is terrible too bad
yeah
i mean which is you've got the fusion
term here yeah we can have it we've used
that for the basic operators for the
generic operators i mean
and a term wouldn't have to be just a
single term it can be
you know multiple terms together
right so so you could have diffusion
term and
what you're saying here is you you say
diffusion term of blah blah blah plus
conservative convection term equals um
right hand side yeah so that that's
basically it's it's a it's a
concatenation in some way of specific
generic terms it's like a higher level
a next level no i understand but i think
it could be a term as well
yeah i think it's not terrible because
people will at least then understand
that that's something
that's not an equation itself it's
something that goes into it exactly
that's what we're saying i see what
you're saying stephen
and then that that thing where it says
yes
i mean transfer term blah blah blah
equals heat flux value
it's not terrible
yeah maybe i'm just concerned about that
people are looking for pde models
you know so we need to that's why we're
going to have a pde model repository
and they'll know we have lots of pde
models
i mean that's a question of
documentation and you know
keywords and so on it's not going to be
a problem it's more important that
people can read the thing we have
you know acoustic term blah blah blah
equals
acoustic about absorbing value
can it end up with acoustic absorbing
value plus acoustic impedance value
yes yes sure you can you can add
multiple boundary conditions i mean they
can be on different different
parts of the boundary so you you need to
be able to add them i see
and you can even have multiple boundary
conditions at the same spot in some
cases
right
so okay i need to go to a different live
stream which which
i encourage people who've been watching
this we are doing a live stream about
code assistance which we'll start
in a moment here um and uh
yeah this is very interesting okay um
i mean um
just trying to think what else we need
to talk about immediately here
um the structure of your thing with with
that that initial would you not
also want to give some uh association
form of the first argument that says
dependent variable arrow blah blah blah
and so on
rather than list do you already have
that
um
what would be the benefit of it it's
useful for documentation
if somebody wants to see exactly how it
works you know they're seeing it in a
textbook and they just see dependent
variable rot
you know independent variable iot and so
on they immediately know what they are
they don't have to
look up documentation i think we should
support it
i think people some people will use it
some people will not people who are just
typing it in won't use it but if they
you know if this is their master
equation and they're going to say it
only once
they'll probably put it in that more
elaborate form because it's more
important that people can read it
than the people i mean if you think
about it in a paper it's a wonderful
self-documenting thing you don't have to
say where blah blah blah is blah blah
blah
blah blah blah
anyway i have to go to this other
meeting but um uh
impressive okay to be continued